the technique of derive variables comes
up in analyzing state machines so let's
just take a quick look at it together so
a derived variable is simply a function
on the states of a state machine that
assigns some value to the states so it's
just a that kind of function mapping if
the values happen to be say that
non-negative integers it's called
non-negative integer valued but it could
be real valued complex valued and even
take on other kinds of odd kinds of
values not necessarily numerical no pun
they're not odd numbers but unusual
values so let's look at the example at
the robot on the grid the states were
pairs of non-negative integers giving
the coordinates of where the robot was
and one of the derive variables that we
found was really useful was the sum
value Sigma of a state which is defined
to be x plus y and this would be a
non-negative integer valued derived
variable so the word derived comes
because we're making it up it's not part
of the specification of the state
machine or part of the program that
defines this better the the state
machine so in the robot example the
actual states were composed of the two
coordinates x and y but the derive
variable that we made up was there some
a sigma another useful derived variable
for that robot example was the the
parity of sigma whether or not the
number was even or odd so so sigma is a
zero one valued variable which takes the
value 0 if the sum is even and 1 if the
sum is odd so in the case of fast
exponentiation we looked at the actual
variable Z which was part of the
invariant in a crucial part in the
program and what we noticed about Z was
that Z was a strictly decreasing and
natural number valued variables matter
of fact we know
that it have that each step but its
values were non-negative integers and
it's strictly decreasing at every step
so that implies by the well ordering
principle that it will take a minimum
value and what we know about the minimum
value of a strictly decreasing variable
is that the algorithm is stuck because
it once he has reached its minimum value
if the machine took another step then it
would get smaller so it can't it means
that the algorithm has to terminate so
this gives you a general methodology for
proving termination find a non negative
integer valued strictly decreasing
variable guarantees the program stops as
a matter of fact you can say sometimes
how long it will take for the program to
stop as we saw with fast exponentiation
it took not Z which was the obvious
bound but in fact log of Z because he
only went down at every step it got
halved at every step so in general the
concept of a strictly decreasing
variable is 1 as shown here that at
every step of the state machine in each
transition it gets strictly smaller a
related idea is a weakly decreasing
variable these are not necessarily
useful for proving termination but they
are often useful as you'll see as we
progress through the term examples where
it helps you analyze the behavior of the
algorithm so a weakly decreasing
variable is one which goes down or stays
constant
it never gets larger so if we looked at
the example of Sigma the sum of the
coordinates that's up and down all over
the place it's neither increasing nor
decreasing the other extreme is the
parity variable pi which was the 0 or 1
according to whether or not the sum of
the coordinates was even or odd and pi
is a constant and that means that it's
both weakly increasing and weakly
decreasing in the degenerate sense that
we
increasing is allowed to say the same in
fact something is weakly increasing and
weakly decreasing if and only if it's a
constant by the way of we used to call
weakly decreasing variables non
increasing which is the standard
terminology in the field and calculus
talk about non increasing functions and
we just found that it caused a lot of
confusion because you have to remember
that non increasing is not the same as
not increasing so there's an example of
a function that is not increasing but
it's certainly not non increasing and if
that didn't register I'll let you think
about it by the way this method of
proving termination by finding a
strictly decreasing a natural number
valued variable generalizes
straightforwardly to a variable which
takes on values from a well-ordered set
of real numbers remember a well ordered
set of real numbers one of the
definitions of it is that it's a set of
numbers where it's impossible to find an
infinite decreasing sequence of values
w0 less than W one depth less than W two
less than W one going on forever if that
can't happen and then the set is called
well-ordered of course the non-negative
integers are the most obvious basic case
but there are a bunch of others
described in the notes and an in general
the termination principle is that if you
can find a strictly decreasing variable
derived variable whose values always
come from a well ordered set that also
is a way to prove termination that's
going to guarantee termination for the
same reason that the variable will have
to take a minimum value that's the other
definition of well-ordered and when it
does that machine can't move anymore